claro y el presidente joe biden calificó
esta ley como la nueva ley
jim crow del siglo 21 la ley que en su
momento se agregaba a los afroamericanos
y es que lo que le pide esta ley a los
las personas que quieran votar por
correo es identificación licencias de
conducción identificación que tengan
fotos en muchos casos los afroamericanos
o los latinos pues no tienen este tipo
de identificaciones para poder ejercer
su derecho al voto por correo y lo que
dicen los críticos de esta nueva ley es
precisamente que pues en los
afroamericanos que normalmente son
trabajadores esenciales que están en
trabajos de salud no se pueden tomar el
día libre para ir a ejercer su derecho
al voto así que precisamente era el voto
por correo el que les estaba dando esta
posibilidad a los afroamericanos a las
minorías en georgia de poder ejercer su
derecho al voto poner entonces de
restricciones sobre este derecho al voto
por correo limitar incluso los centros
de votación que se van a poner en el
estado de georgia para las futuras
al senado y a la presidencia pues limita
a las personas que estaban acudiendo al
voto por correo para poder ejercer su
derecho al voto y estas personas pues
terminan siendo en su mayoría
afroamericanos y latinos baiden al
respecto ha dicho que va a hacer todo lo
posible para impulsar desde el congreso
una ley ley federal electoral para poder
poner límite a esto normalmente las
leyes electorales son estatales
cristóbal sabemos que históricamente yo
ya ha sido un bastión republicano para
en 2020 se convirtió en lo que llamamos
un estado bisagra que cambió de
preferencia partidista al darle sus
votos a vaivén y elegir los dos
congresistas para los demócratas con los
que lograron el control del senado es
por esto que los republicanos están
impulsando este tipo de leyes
claro y de hecho el líder del senado
extraction me está diciendo que los
republicanos en vez de tratar de
convencer a los votantes que perdieron
en las elecciones pasadas lo que están
tratando de hacer es limitar su derecho
al voto restringirlo sobre todo en el
tema del voto por correo y es que hay
que recordar que fueron los 16 votos
electorales de georgia los que ayudaron
mucho a que yo baile llegar a la casa
blanca y es precisamente el voto por
correo el que termina dándole esa
ventaja al final en los re conteos que
fueron más de 3 reconteo y también fue
el voto por correo el que le da la
victoria a los dos senadores de georgia
que le aseguraron entonces la mayoría al
partido demócrata en la cámara alta en
el senado así que precisamente por eso
esto lo que quieren atacar los
republicanos el voto por correo para
pues limitar a los demócratas en futuras
elecciones y pues lo que quieren lograr
los demócratas es ampliar esa libertad
de voto para asegurar pues en nuevas
victorias en el futuro